nous sommes ici à dharavi c'est le plus
grand bidonville d'asie et la moitié des
habitants de mumbai vivent dans des
habitations comme celle là des
habitations très très modeste pourquoi
parce qu'il ya une énorme pénurie de
logement ici une grave crise du logement
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
à dharavi l'espace est tellement
restreint qu'il faut savoir utiliser la
rue comme extension de sa maison ce
gigantesque bidonville renferme près
d'un million de personnes dans à peine
deux petits kilomètres carrés pour
gagner de la place
les logements sont perchés au dessus des
ruelles
comme dans la bêtise il est surpris si
bien watson vient sous presse aucun
succès novellino route et la famille de
courbes à ben habite donc uniquement
dans cette pièce qui semble pourtant
être qu'une cuisine le soir la grand
mère et un couple doivent coucher à
l'extérieur dans le quartier certains
dorment même à tour de rôle
mumbai détient le triste record mondial
pour le nombre de personnes vivant dans
des bidonvilles
mais détrompez vous c'est ce l'homme
comme on les appelle ici ne sont pas
peuplé que de mendiants ou de chômeurs
des travailleurs de la petite classe
moyenne doivent aussi habité et michel
gaudin métrages et de camargo jamais
malgré l'immense densité d'immeubles il
manque encore cruellement d'habitation à
mumbai il en faudrait des millions
supplémentaires pour loger tout le monde
correctement mumbai est une des villes
où les loyers augmentent le plus vite au
monde
le marché immobilier et même plus cher
ici qu'à toronto où berlin dans les
quartiers les plus prisés du
centre-ville un logement d'une seule
chambre seul ou entre 1000 et 5000 $ par
mois
il faut gagner au moins 300 mille
dollars par année pour espérer s'acheter
un appartement à cet endroit
et encore ce ne sera peut-être pas
suffisant comble de l'ironie dans cette
ville où le revenu moyen est de 20
milles dollars par année
mumbai abrite la maison la plus chère au
monde cette tour qui est la résidence de
l'industriel indien mukesh ambani fait
27 étages on y trouve 600 pièces et
autant de domestique
il y a six étages de stationnement 9
ascenseurs des jardins une salle de gym
une piscine cinéma et 3 héliport mais
revenons les pieds sur terre
à l'ombre des gratte-ciel des familles
modestes ont décidé coûte que coûte de
vivre centre ville pour s'éviter deux
trois heures ou plus de trafic par jour
c'est le cas denis l'achat et sa famille
qui vivent à 5 dans seize mètres carrés
les alcools
le fils chirag gagne 850 $ par mois en
travaillant dans une banque
mais ce n'est même pas assez d'argent
pour louer un petit appartement comme
celui là pour lui et sa femme de toute
façon ça ne l'intéresse pas de quitter
ses parents sa mère de famille de
modèles double irresponsable de nos
jeunes occupent des locaux des villes de
la grand-mère sourya ben 79 ans est bien
heureuse d'être entouré de ses proches
quand elle est tombée s'est cassé la
hanche récemment quelqu'un était là pour
elle nous avons remis les prix et pour m
il y a des choses en inde qui ne
changent pas comme l'amour du criquet et
d'autres qui évoluent c'est ainsi que de
plus en plus de couples veulent
maintenant voler de leurs propres ailes
ce qui met de la pression sur la demande
de logements rope ali et son mari mayur
tous les deux dans la trentaine ont
emménagé il ya un mois dans ce conte 12
2 chambres en banlieue de mumbai montant
payé 200 mille dollars la moitié de leur
revenu mensuel sert à payer l'hypothèque
c'était probablement la question de
l'intimité mais c'était une sorte de
désir d expérimenter de vivre toute
seule et gérer tout ça comme on voit
dans le monde occidental il y a les gens
qui sortent à l'âge de 18 ans est ici
quand on a besoin d'eux expérimenté ça
mais où nous ce qui est important c'est
de ne pas séparer complètement de ses
parents donc mes beaux-parents donc deux
ou trois jours par semaine on va aller
rester chez eux chez eux et ont après 3
quel jour on vient ici
deuxième raison c'est aussi pour
l'investissement parce qu on recevra pas
de votre fait
en l'absence d'un véritable système de
retraite les aînés n'ont que leurs
enfants sur qui compter des enfants qui
sont la force vive de ce pays en pleine
croissance qui deviendra bientôt le plus
peuplé au monde devant la chine
un indien sur deux n'a même pas encore
30 ans 1 m à 24 ans d'assigner fondement
wolton salue nos climats lettre comme et
sa robe girly salle banal
[Musique]